terrence davis on the floor
another rebound ball number nine all
behind the backpack
bridge is it
hayward somehow found bridges
open look lamellar
folks in charlotte should be very
excited about it we're going to see
lamelo ball right now jeffy checked in
during the timeout
wearing number two for charlotte pj
washington from ball
won the g-back star the global biorisk
advisory council
david i don't have to tell you what that
is the g-back star is the gold standard
for safe
facilities the first two games against
toronto
he's knocked down four tonight cole
anthony has it taken away
ball on the lob and reaching way back is
miles bridges
pulling on the pulling for these
teammates here in the closing minutes
james springer trying to work out some
guys as well
what a pass by ball leading monk
beautifully down the open floor
running him off that three-point line
giving up mid-range twos
all of a sudden fighting it he's got a
quick six
oh crafty off of a hornet
picked up by lamela ball with two hands
first nba dunk everything that happened
since march in the with the nba taking
some time off really helped his recovery
and his rehab and
he was able to take his time gordon
hayward hornets have swapped out centers
with bismarck biambo
out and playing small ball center is pj
washington
great anticipation by lamelo and it's
blocked away
picked up by hayward pj with two hands
offensive rebound cody martin extra
possession for the hornets
ball miles is still perfect
final minute lavello
rings the bell from distance devonta
catch and shoot offensive rebound lamelo
oh what a wondrous corner for the
charlotte hornets down in dallas texas
it's like he bought a skill with him
that's to put it in the air and put it
in the hole
so this guy first time he touched it
oh flutter got a skill with him is what
lamelo
22 points on wednesday in dallas working
against jang the spin
score it out the window work is good
lamello
that's nice just jumped on top of ty
yeah
and he was almost too far to shoot that
with the left hand that's why he
switched it to the right
lamelo starting to feel it double
figures for the kid
ah goodness kids got game where he
learned that dell
playgrounds charlotte nice steal lamella
ball
[Applause]
oh my goodness really joel embiid falls
down and lamelo scored
lamello
pretty with the left hand and he's from
heaven
oh my goodness hornets are gonna get
another buck and a full-length pass to
lamelo
that is how you end a quarter
[Applause]
driving on lamello ball here's lonzo
ball
and williamson turns it over lamella
ball with the pick and the nice feed in
transition
that's where his improvement has been
the best part
is his three-point shooting game a
beautiful pass
by ball to biambo
and the pelicans are the number one
rebounding team in the league
lamelo over his brother lonzo hits a
three
this was behind the defense horton can't
find him
lamelo eyes everywhere left-handed pass
to rozier
off the dribble right on the money
two for one mode i guess lamelo leaves
it for pj
all swirls
[Applause]
atlanta get pretty good looks from three
only eight of 22. oh lamela ball
every which way but loose his second
field goal
this is his first shot full length
baseball pass
[Applause]
it's going 2 for 11. wow what a steal by
lamelo
he was all over the place defensively
cody martin scored at a foul
of yet lamelo
shot clocks at four
strong with a left hand about that how
about that presence of mine for a real
threat
[Music]
lamello
[Applause]
with contact i think a lot of people
forget he was a relative
journeyman when he came into the league
a lot of different teams
pj washington beautiful find by lamelo
wanted to fit their last five shots in
the field
devonte at six in a row a three-pointer
for davonte graham
big call drink water seven footer matt
geiger yeah
[Applause]
devonta the misfire and lamelo great
anticipation gets the ball back for the
hornets
lamelo back out clean look there you go
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my goodness pj just got knocked out
of the way all the
in the spot lamella ball
off the bench doing a good job they did
a great job the other night with that
looking for that night in night out
consistency here's ball
the deep three in his career averaging
close to 20 points
in his four seasons when playing against
the hornets
lamelo such a significant force here in
the chicago or in the charlotte area and
entire north carolina and what he has
done to try and get everyone involved
if you've watched any highlight film the
full oh hello
he's not afraid to shoot it wow that was
fearless going inside and he just took
it away from temple
well i didn't see that dunk trying to
dump there
the pass to graham for three lamelo
coming off uh
a season low 16 minutes in friday's loss
against chicago
interior pass and beauty and lavello
finds cody zeller
so far orlando shooting 64 9-14 from the
field
and one how about that lamela ball got
all the way to the cup
score it birch another offensive rebound
hornets the other way already leading by
seven lamello
oh and and one the strength for the
young fella
pass deflected bridges
lamelo oh yeah lamela ball beats the
buzzer
mcdermott's got seven points off the
bench and lamelo
score the goal and one
[Applause]
four of them are first-round picks here
comes pj the steal
lavello there you go
seven quick points off the bench for the
mellow ball
he's falling out of bounds and threw a
beautiful pass to devonta
oh my goodness didn't see that coming
devonte leads the ball game 19 year old
rookie lamellar ball checks in for the
first time
16 points yesterday against indiana
straight on look rozier
got it all right one possession game one
it's down three
middleton two-time all-star again lamelo
ahead of the pack
this time leaves it for hayward hornets
lead by five
[Applause]
lamello got it string music
[Applause]
bad pass hayward's got it numbers for
the hornets
lamello scoring
oh the kids come of age ball fake and
the slide to his left
great footwork there by duncan to get
that three ball up
ball missed the triple robinson's pass
deflected off the underside of the
backboard
ball powering it up and in lanello ball
then try to get it to him the free-throw
line and he'd go the other way and knock
down another three
gordon hayward back over to lamello deep
three all right first three ball for
lamellar ball
hornets playing without pj washington
for the first time on the season
lamello got it three ball deep one right
off the catch pull the trigger
get it back here comes lamela ball with
his hair on fire
jabari parker is now out of the lead
patient move and patience of virtue
it's rewarded a chance for a three-point
play
and that'll probably be the final shot
of the game
oh no the mellow took it from embiid you
okay with that dell
yeah oh and a three
here comes lamelo dumps down cody
there's your first bucket of the ball
game
right there patience didn't force that
three early
i think because they play so well on the
defensive end quinn snyder's looses them
up a little bit offensively
lamelo all right great ball for the
rookie
bogdanovic off the heel
here come the hornets lamello
gorgeous drive oh the rookie
coast to coast he's got 12 points
lamello uh bottom of the well
[Applause]
with the left hand
[Applause]
the confidence to step back and bottom a
triple
oh lavello the youngster
answers
lamello gets it back from hayward and
with the left hand
the 19 year old has figured out the pro
game
beale had five quick ones to begin the
ball game
coming off the game where he only made
one shot against miami hey lavell
ball from deez downtown
[Applause]
a lot of times you get you get fouled
you wanna that
shooting motion call to get three shots
they'll give you that
lamelo second three-pointer of the game
what it's lead by 11. long three
oh
third three-pointer of the first half
when he takes shots from behind that
line one and done oladipo the misfire
oh look at that squeeze lamelo somehow
got it to cody
he saw cody open earlier
tate pass intercepted by malik here
comes lamelo again
looking ahead of the pack that's how you
throw that one
mclemore still hot
two-point ball game five-point ball game
second three-pointer for lamelo bridges
has added 10
for them as well all of his points
coming in the second quarter both
hayward and ball scoring nine
each in the second ball will start the
third quarter off with another
made three oladipo has to be able to
occupy that
stop and pop three
four on three the other way pull-up ball
wow how about that confidence deflection
is a big story for memphis
they lead the world in deflections this
year and a steal by lamelo off to the
races
there's your first basket of the ball
game it's 28 made threes
that's a career high for him already
pj hangs in the air long enough get it
to about oh and the reverse is good the
movement of the hornets
he turned down a layup try to get a
three
ball who re circulated back to him
lavello good start for the 19 year old
took his mouthpiece out and had
something to say the official
loose lavello's got it one man to beat
oh at the rim pj
ricky rubio creative bounce pass stolen
away by lamelo
hornets down three just getting started
hayward
leaves it to lamella who got pushed from
behind and score it
head of the pack hayward
gets his own miss got another miss
oh my goodness the unfortunate drill
lamella ball just wanted it more
the screen and roll and then up and
under with a hang time
lamella answers with a three of his
own and three is better than two how
about that
lamelo
lamarcus aldridge veteran low post
presence
he is out for the foreseeable future
terry rozier
oh he's been doing that exquisitely
that's good d by miles as well
lamelo hard charging off the window and
then
[Applause]
devonte and one thing lamellar does well
is anticipate
like that he anticipated he's going to
get that ball and was ready to fire
as soon as he did
[Applause]
and lamelo great anticipation two on one
lavello
after a white hot second quarter where
they couldn't miss the spurs are only
two of nine here in the third and
another three-pointer
dropped in by lamelo ball
we're underway hornets have the
basketball
whip around pass a beauty lavello finds
pj washington here's lumello
streaking down the floor malik monk
bottom of the well again give the assist
to lamello
kemba walker went to boston and kind of
a de facto switch
with rozier and kemba that one-handed
pass
stolen and rozier headed the other way
just stop at the three-point line
i heard somebody you'll travel but yeah
you left the wrong guy
out of the basketball left him open
lamela tries to answer
[Applause]
stumbled lamelo he's got ingles on him
another crossover oh
gorgeous score it with the left hand
george niang clarkson misses twice same
possession that was off balance on that
one
lamelo darts inside score another one
for the 19 year old
jazz down two first game of his six-game
road trip for the hornets lamelo took it
away from mitchell
two on one rozier
and no one holds it against him the fact
that he hasn't won the whole ball of wax
steal by lamela ball and a fine rozier
score the goal nice anticipation there
by
lamelo
[Applause]
rocking his first tar heels jersey with
the number 23 across
the back they knew he was a basketball
star early on kim actually played on his
older brother's aau
fourth grade team when he was just in
the first grade the shot from three
booker was open paul didn't see him
lamelo has eaten on it starts through
at the rim oh take
that big man when he sees somebody bite
he's going to make you pay
communication is going to be key for the
hornets on a defensive end
well now the ball splashes his first
triple
rodriguez says slow it down let's get
organized
now this may be the new warriors they're
doing it in the paint
hey lavello ball he's been sensational
here in the first quarter
and lamelo forces the issue score it and
a foul
usually the first sub in the game is
miles bridges for the hornets these days
and miles is in okay so miles and malik
coming at the same time
shot clocks down to two and lamelo spins
it in with his off hand
knocked away from behind good job by
lamelo final minute big shot for terry
there you go this is really easy for
damian lillard
coming off a 30-plus point performance
in that loss against the lakers and
one lamar where you pointed out when he
landed on the foot of a laker didn't
quite move the same for the rest of the
game as ball
gets his first bucket of the game
they're part of a crew of teams in the
eastern conference
sitting there with 17 losses they're in
the eight spots trying to hold their
ground until they get healthy
ball a deep three lillard
attacking martin trying to feed it to
jones jr
stolen by ball rozier will t one up from
outside
is mounting up against him is to get
that other guard on his side
have a middle outlet and then have two
people on opposite sides
a little bit down the floor covington
eight for eight five of five from three
that ties this season high
21 points and ball for the stuff
five-point ball game three-point ball
game left-handed lay-up lamellar ball
a little hitch that is a tough shot even
though he was in that short corner three
triples for rubio in this game lavell
rings the bell